y aunque vive a miles de kilómetros de
su natal ucrania la vida de natasha
también cambió de golpe el 24 de febrero
las cajas de medicina rosa lo que era
una empresa de venta de productos de
belleza y demostraciones de cocina se ha
convertido en un centro de acopio de
ayuda para los afectados por la guerra
este es una cocina o sea todo esto ahora
mismo es son medicamentos que luego
nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es comprar
las neveras para poder mandar no también
en frío y que llegue bien en hasta
ucrania y en nuestras manos en lo que
tenemos algo ahora mismo pues eso es lo
que tenemos que hacer es ayudar y si hoy
por ejemplo no hago una limpieza facial
y no cobro dinero
o sea ellos tienen menos ellos han
quedado sin casas
uno de los muchos voluntarios que
reciben y organizan lo que va llegando
es nahuel la pareja de natasha un
argentino residente en madrid dueño de
una inmobiliaria que acaba de volver de
polonia de traer a varios refugiados
ucranianos nosotros al final no fuimos
de nuestro país por decisión propia y
todo hemos perdido esencia cuando te vas
de tu país y ver que eso es al final se
lo arrebatan y una decisión imaginamos
que el nuestro dolor todavía es mucho
más grande el derecho perfecto esta
semana es jose el que emprende la misma
travesía que hizo nahuel este texto por
donde recoges a la gente si seis mujeres
y niños volverán con este maestro de
pedagogía que deja de lado su trabajo y
a su familia durante unos días es una
suerte poder hacerlo luego y muy
contento de poder hacerlo ahora no me
supone un esfuerzo el máximo esfuerzo ha
sido que tengo un niño de 3 años alonso
que lo voy a dejar
de una semana pero creo que cuando él
sea mayor lo entenderá mientras josé
recorre kilómetros la actividad en el
local de natasha no cesa comienza una
nueva operación logística para enviar
más ayuda a ucrania